London for the London Cuda meetup and Pi Data London, then Budapest for a day for the Budapest Python meetup, then Hamburg for ISC and the Hamburg C++ meetup, and then Ramona and her 14-year-old niece joined me there. Welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 243 recorded on July 1st, 2025. My name is Connor and today with my co-host Bryce, we chat about learning languages. We recap some recent C++, CUDA and Python meetups and more. Say something. Hello. Hello. All right. Shush. Am I saying that right?
伦敦参加伦敦 Cuda 聚会和 Pi Data London，然后去布达佩斯参加了一天的布达佩斯 Python 聚会，接着去汉堡参加 ISC 和汉堡 C++ 聚会，然后 Ramona 和她 14 岁的侄女在那里和我汇合。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 243 期，录制于 2025 年 7 月 1 日。我是 Connor，今天我和我的联合主持人 Bryce 一起聊聊学习语言。我们回顾了一些最近的 C++、CUDA 和 Python 聚会等等。说点什么。你好。你好。好了。嘘。我发音对吗？
I've been learning Polish. I've been learning Polish with the with the apps and that is not a word. Yeah, it is. Yeah. Oh, it's chest. There we go. Shush. I love this.
我一直在学波兰语。我一直在用应用程序学波兰语，那不是一个词。是的，它是。是的。哦，是 chest。就是这样。嘘。我喜欢这个。
So so really you're recording. Yeah. I'm recording. I'm recording. I'm recording. I'm recording. I'm recording. I'm recording.
所以，你真的在录音吗？是的。我在录音。我在录音。我在录音。我在录音。我在录音。我在录音。
I'm recording. I'm recording. I'm recording. I'm recording. I'm chest. There we go. I love this. So, so reading from the recording. I am. Yeah. Okay. Okay. Good. Reading from the transcript, the AI transcript, it's S H I S H as what I thought I said. And then it says Connor. What is chic? Chic.
我在录音。我在录音。我在录音。我在录音。我是 chest。就是这样。我喜欢这个。所以，从录音中读出来。我是。是的。好的。好的。很好。从转录稿，AI 转录稿中读出来，是 S H I S H，我以为我说了这个。然后它写着 Connor。什么是 chic？Chic。
And then Connor says, oh, it's chest. And then Bryce, chest. There we go, chest. Well I'm probably, I haven't, I mean I did like a ton of Polish at one point. Yeah, I remember. Chest, it's one of the harder things to say actually because it's like CZESC or something like that. Yeah, it's got two, it's got like three of the letters that we don't have. Yeah. Anyways, it's definitely not sheish though, I can tell you that. I even practiced before we got on the call and you can see how that
然后 Connor 说，哦，是 chest。然后 Bryce 说，chest。就是这样，chest。好吧，我可能，我还没，我是说我曾经非常努力地学过波兰语。是的，我记得。Chest，这其实是最难发音的东西之一，因为它像 CZESC 之类的。是的，它有两个，它有三个我们没有的字母。是的。不管怎样，肯定不是 sheish，我可以告诉你。我甚至在通话前练习过，你可以看到它是怎么
went. An easier one and more impressive in my opinion is Shepresham which I believe is I'm sorry or excuse me so if you're like walking around you just say oh Shepresham. I'll have to remember that one because you know I'm a very clumsy person, so I'm constantly bumping into my girlfriend around the apartment. Yeah, to take a small little tangent, even though we have lots of more exciting things to talk about, I have such a bone to pick with all these language learning apps. Yeah, I was just about to ask, the reason I tried to speak Polish to you was I was going to ask for your advice on what's the best way to learn because I tried Duolingo and
进行的。在我看来，一个更容易且更令人印象深刻的是 Shepresham，我相信是“对不起”或“打扰一下”的意思，所以如果你在四处走动，你只要说，哦，Shepresham。我得记住那个，因为你知道，我是一个非常笨拙的人，所以我经常在公寓里撞到我女朋友。是的，稍微跑个题，尽管我们还有很多更令人兴奋的事情要谈，但我对所有这些语言学习应用程序真的很有意见。是的，我正要问，我试着对你说波兰语的原因是我正要征求你的建议，关于学习的最佳方式是什么，因为我试过 Duolingo，
it immediately bothered me because I like I, when I tried Duolingo I just put in that like I have no knowledge because like I know a couple of Polish words but like I just wanted to start from like the most basics. And so it started like teaching me, but it doesn't explain anything. It doesn't explain conjugation. It doesn't like, it just does everything through examples. And you're supposed to learn through inference, which is, maybe that's the way, but I wanted something
它立刻让我感到困扰，因为我，当我尝试 Duolingo 时，我只是输入了我没有任何知识，因为我确实知道几个波兰语单词，但我只是想从最基础的开始。所以它开始教我，但它什么都不解释。它不解释变位。它不，它只是通过例子来做所有事情。你本应该通过推断来学习，这，也许那是种方法，但我想要一些
where it's going to explain to me, these are the different forms and that's how you do like conjugation and something like that. And also I'm terrible at pronunciation. I want an app where it's going to have where like for me to make progress, I have to speak the words correctly and it will grade how well I've spoken them. So Duolingo does do that at some point. It just gets introduced a
能向我解释的东西，这些是不同的形式，这就是你如何做变位之类的。而且我的发音很糟糕。我想要一个应用程序，它能让我为了取得进步，必须正确地说出单词，并且它会给我的发音打分。所以 Duolingo 在某种程度上确实做到了。它只是在稍后一点才引入。所以是的，对于，我的意思是，作为背景，我曾经在 2012 年说得很好，我曾经在某个时候说一点波兰语。我也，所以我已经在 Duolingo 上做过中文了。我做过波兰语。我，有时我也胡乱学一点西班牙语、荷兰语或日语。但我的，所以他们确实有口语，他们确实有，你知道，如果你想要的话可以拼写，但你可以在设置中切换。不过我的主要问题是他们让你开始学习的单词，我在想最近的一个，我想是
little bit later. And so yeah, for I mean for a background I mean I used to speak Chinese very well like back in 2012 and I spoke a little bit of Polish at one point. I've also so I've done Chinese on Duolingo. I've done Polish. I've and sometimes I've messed around like learning a little bit of Spanish or Dutch or Japanese. But my and so they they do do speaking they do do the You know spelling if you want kind of but you can kind of toggle that in the settings my main issue Though is the words that they start you with like I'm trying to think what the most recent one I think it was I
我重新下载了它，开始学习一点日语，而且，他们不，在最初的七到十节课里，你学不到“是”或“不是”或“谢谢”或类似的东西，而且，通常你想要它是为了对话目的，或者，你知道，它是，而且在最初的七到十个单词里，我正在学习“医生”和“律师”。我只是觉得，我不喜欢，我不觉得你需要，你应该学习的第一件事应该是“是”、“不是”、“打扰一下”、“对不起”。然后就像，甚至他们还问，你用这个做什么？就像，哦，通常人们选择的是旅行或基本对话。我理解他们需要引入几个名词，比如苹果之类的。但我总是很震惊，在他们开始引入你之前，你已经学了那么久，数字也非常重要。比如很多时候当你点餐时，你想要能够说一、二或不管怎样。所以我知道 Duolingo 非常成功，我也应该提到我正在积极学习波斯语，但 Duolingo 不支持波斯语。有趣。
Redownloaded it and started learning a bit of Japanese and like, they don't, in the first like seven or ten lessons you don't learn yes or no or thank you or like, and like I, usually you want it for conversational purposes or like, you know, it's like, and in the first seven or ten words I'm learning doctor and lawyer. And I'm just like, I don't like, I don't need like the first things you should learn are like, yes, no, excuse me, I'm sorry. And then it's like, like, even they even asked, like, what are you using this for? And it's like, oh, usually what what people choose is like travel or like basic conversation. And I understand that they need to introduce like a couple nouns like Apple or something like that. But I'm always shocked like how far you get into it before they start like introducing you like in numbers is also very important. Like a lot of times when you're ordering something you want to be able to say like one two or anyway. So I know Dua Dua Lingo is very successful and I should mention to I also am actively learning Persian, but Duolingo doesn't support Persian. Interesting.
所以我必须使用另一个叫 Mondly 的应用程序。我也试过其他几个。它们都很糟糕。Duolingo 是最好的。但我认为这个领域已经成熟，可以被某种 LLM 颠覆，基本上你可以说，这是，我想进行这种对话，教我这些种类的单词。你绝对是对的，他们从不，就像在 Mondly 里，
So I have to use a different app called Mondly. And I've tried a couple others. All of them are terrible. Duolingo is the best. But I think this space is ripe for disruption with like some LLM where basically you can just say like, this is, I want to have this kind of conversation and teach me these kinds of words. And you're definitely correct. They never, like in in Mondly,
我每天做的所有波斯语，它从不教你变位。基本上，幸运的是我的伴侣是波斯人。所以我可以直接问。很多时候，当我和你的家人在一起时，我会利用这个机会，而且应用程序给你的发音非常非常正式，所以
with all the Persian that I do daily, it never teaches you the conjugations. Basically like luckily my partner is Persian. And so I can just ask. And a lot of times when I'm like hanging out with your family, I'll like take the opportunity to, and the pronunciations that the app gives you are very very formal and so
他们总是给我一颗心，他们说，啊，那不是“房子”的发音，是 who then that honey，我说，好吧，我的意思是应用程序上的女士说 honey，所以我应该怎么知道呢？不管怎样，所以这就像这里有一个巨大的机会，让某个应用程序进来，就像 Duolingo 在游戏化方面很棒，但在我看来，在让你达到你所说的理解变位的地方，他们实际上相当糟糕。而且，你还有你的核心词汇集。这条路径，我相信他们做过研究，但我保证他们是在优化留存率，而不是真正地……
they always give me a heart and they're like ah that's not how you pronounce house it's who then that honey and I'm like well I mean the lady on the app says honey so like what am I supposed to know and anyways so it's just like there is a massive opportunity here for some app to come in like Duolingoolingo is amazing at the gamification, but in my opinion, they're actually quite terrible at getting you in a place where you understand, like you said, conjugations. And also, you have your core set of vocabulary. The path, I'm sure they've done studies, but I guarantee you they're optimizing for retention, not actually...
是的，是的。好吧，我有一个关于这个的理论，所以这很有趣。我有同样的感觉，因为对于波兰语，它教的前几个词是男人、女人、男孩、女孩，然后。哦，是的。那些非常难。Jivchenka，女孩是。这不是一个简单的词。然后他们还教你“吃”这个词，因为女孩是，这不是一个简单的词，然后他们还教你
Yeah, yeah. Well, I have a theory about so it's interesting. I felt the same way because like for the Polish, the first couple words it taught is like man, woman, boy, girl, and then. Oh, yeah. And those are very hard. Jivchenka like for girl is. It's not a simple word. And then they also teach you the word for eating, because the like for girl is it's not a simple word and then they also teach you the word
“吃”这个词，因为“吃”这个词和“我的”这个词非常相似，我的理论是，他们教你“吃”这个词的原因是它和你如何说“我是”非常相似，所以如果你没有在早期被教导“吃”这个词的意思，你会感到困惑。因为它就像，是的，对吧？对于，是吃。然后这和你如何说，比如，yes them，也就是“我是”，非常相似。哦，yes them，是的。是的，是的。
for eating because the word for eating is very similar to the word for my theory is that the reason that they teach you the word for eating is that it's very similar to how you say am and so you get if you didn't get taught what the word for eating meant early on, you would get confused. Because it's like, yeah, right? For like, is eating. And then that's very similar to how you would say, like, yes, them, which is like, I am. Oh, yes, them, yeah. Yeah, yeah.
然后他们，但他们也教你，你知道，比如牛奶、面包、苹果。我想苹果、男人、男孩、女人、女孩是前五个词。我确实觉得有点奇怪。有一件事我想到的是，也许他们从具体名词开始，因为他们有这种图画元素，他们向你展示句子，比如你知道在句子中，比如你要翻译的是“我是一个男孩”，它有一个可爱的小男孩的象形图，然后对于“我是一个女人”，你知道，他们有一个可爱的女人象形图，也许他们做了一些研究，他们确定如果你，如果你做出视觉联系，你会学得更好。
And then they, but then they also teach you like, you know, like milk, bread, apple. I think apple man, boy, woman, girl were the first five words. I did find it a little weird. One thing that occurred to me is that perhaps they start off with concrete nouns because they have this pictorial element where they show you the sentence like you know in the sentence like you're gonna translate is like I am a boy and it's got a little cute like pictograph of a little boy and then for like I am a woman you know they've got a cute little pictograph of a woman and maybe they did some research and they determined that you if if like you make a visual connection you're gonna learn better.
但我试过另一个叫 Babble 的应用程序。我——是的，也试过那个。Babble 教你的第一件事是如何说“是”和“不是”。我更喜欢 Babble，因为我觉得它在解释事情方面做得更好。它解释说，nay，
But I tried another app called Babble. And I- Yeah, try that one as well. The first thing that Babble taught you was how to say yes and no. And I liked Babble better because I felt like it did a better job of explaining things. It explained that like, nay,
或者我肯定发音错了。这是你说“不”的方式，但然后它解释说，它可以意味着“不”也意味着“不是”，并且它被用于否定，它在解释差异方面做得很好。然后它也开始解释波兰语中的一些不同声音，比如 zh。它做了类比，比如这个声音
or I'm sure I'm pronouncing that wrong. It's how you say no, but then like it explains that like, it can mean no and also not, and that like it's used for negation, and it did a good job of explaining the differences. And then it also started explaining some of the different sounds in Polish like, zh. And it like made analogies to like this sound
对于波兰字母 RZ。它做了类比，这听起来就像你如何说 pleasure 中的 S。我和我女朋友一起做这个特别的练习，她说，哦，那非常聪明。我从来没想过那样向人们解释。但这正是我的想法。这就是非常好的语言老师，就像我学中文时，
for like the Polish letter Polish letter RZ. It made the analogy like this sounds like how you'd say the S in pleasure. And I was doing this particular one with my girlfriend and she was like, oh, that's very clever. I've never thought of explaining it to people like that. But that's exactly how I would think of it. That's what really good language teachers, like when I was learning Chinese,
那是其中一件事，比如 R，他们说了完全一样的话，比如 shir，这就像一个非常软的 R。这就是中文里以 R 开头的单词的发音方式，很多时候，比如我认为 urban 是 Japan，而且它就像，它是最难发音的单词之一。所以他们会用这样的技巧。所以，这实际上是真正好的
that was one of the things like the R, they said exactly the same thing, like the shir, which is like a really soft R. That's how words that start with R in Chinese, a lot of the times, like I think urban is Japan, and it's like, it's one of the harder words to pronounce. And so they do tricks like that. So like, that's actually what really good
语言导师和语言老师所做的。他们给你一个类比，把你所知道的和你自己语言中的说法联系起来，对吧？是的。但这很有趣，因为我一直认为我在语言方面真的很差。最终激励我做这件事的事情是我们在保加利亚的 C++ 委员会会议上。
like language tutors and language teachers do. They give you some analogy that ties back to what you know how to say in your own language, right? Yeah. But it's funny, because I've always thought I've been like really bad at languages. And the thing that finally inspired me to do this was we were at the C++ committee meeting in bulk area.
在那之前，我们在汉堡参加 ISC。在过去的一个月里，为了这次 CUDA 之旅，我去了八个国家。惊喜，惊喜。是的，所以整个行程是伦敦参加伦敦 CUDA 聚会和 Pi Data London，然后去布达佩斯参加了一天的布达佩斯 Python 聚会，接着去汉堡参加 ISC 和汉堡 C++ 聚会。
And before that, we were at ISC in Hamburg. I've been to eight countries in the past month for this CUDA tour of a year. Surprise, surprise. Yeah, so the whole itinerary was London for the London CUDA meetup and Pi Data London, then Budapest for a day for the Budapest Python Meetup, then Hamburg for ISC and the Hamburg C++ Meetup.
然后 Ramona 和她 14 岁的侄女在那里和我汇合。她的侄女，她会说一些英语，但还不够流利。所以如果她和我一对一交谈，我们用手机，我们用手机上的谷歌翻译。然后我们从汉堡去了保加利亚的委员会会议。然后那里还有另一个聚会，在索非亚。它是由 NVIDIA 赞助的，虽然我实际上没有发言。我的同事 Gunzel 最后代替我发言了。然后我在土耳其，在马德里。但我只是觉得，每次我遇到 Ramona 的家人，他们大多数人只是说波兰语。
And then Ramona and her 14-year-old niece joined me there. And her niece, she speaks some English, but she's not fluent yet. And so if her and I are talking one-on-one, we're using the phone, we're using Google Translate on the phone. And then we went from Hamburg to the committee meeting in Bulgaria. And then there was another meetup there in Sofia. It was sponsored by NVIDIA, although I didn't actually speak it. My colleague, Gunzel, ended up speaking at it instead. And then I was in Turkey, in Madrid. But I was just like, every time I run into Ramona's family, most of them just speak Polish.
就像你坐着吃午饭，其他人都在用波兰语交谈，你无法跟上。所以我当时想，好吧，终于到了。三年后，我需要开始学习了。但我一直有这种看法，认为我不可能学习其他语言，因为我的发音真的很差。我从小学到初中到高中学了八到十年的西班牙语。
And it's like you're sitting and having lunch, and everyone else talking in Polish, and you're not going to be able to keep up. So I was like, all right, finally it's time. After three years, I need to start learning. But I always had this perception that it was just going to be impossible for me to learn other languages because I'm really bad at pronunciation. And I took eight or 10 years of Spanish from elementary through middle school through high school.
我几乎没记住什么西班牙语。然后我在大学里学了拉丁语，因为你必须有语言要求。我对拉丁语的理论是它是一门死语言。他们不能强迫你说一门死语言，而且我的发音很差。但事实证明我错了。他们没有强迫我们在课堂上说拉丁语。但我也没有记住什么。这可能，我的意思是听起来你确实有挣扎的历史，但应用程序在我看来并没有帮助你。我认为有一个机会
And I've retained like no Spanish. And then I took Latin in college because you had to have a language requirement. And my theory behind Latin was it's a dead language. They can't make you speak a dead language and I'm bad at pronunciation. But it turns out I was wrong. They didn't make us speak Latin in class. But I also retained like none of that. It's probably I mean it sounds like you do have a history of struggling but it is it is the apps are not helping you in my opinion. I I think that there's an opportunity for
有一个应用程序，它真的让你沉浸在去一个国家并不得不开始说话的感觉中。就像我搬到中国之前学了七个月的中文。我认为我在搬到中国后的第一周学到的东西比我在那之前的七个月里学到的还要多，因为就像你知道每周一、二、三小时，而且那是唯一的时间，然后当然你在旁边学了一点点，相比之下你去那里，每一次互动，你基本上就像，当然，几乎每个人
an app out there that is really like kind of immerses you in what it's like to just go to a country and having to start speaking. Like it is like I studied Chinese for like seven months before I moved there. I think I learned more in the first week having moved to China than I did in the seven months leading up to it because it's like you know one two three hours a week like and and that's the only time and then sure you're studying a tiny bit on the side versus you go there and every single interaction, you basically like, sure, like almost everyone
在中国都会说英语，但他们不指望切换到英语。你肯定会遇到想练习英语的人，但大多数情况下，当你去，你知道，地铁或出去吃饭时，那是你必须使用的语言。所以很快，你被迫，你会惊讶地发现一旦你
in China speaks English, but they don't expect to switch to English. Like you definitely run into people that wanna practice their English, but for the most part, when you're going on, you know, subways or out to eat, like that's the language you have to operate in. So very quickly, like you are forced and you'd be surprised how fast once you
开始那样做，它就开始强化你在脑海中学习的所有东西，但它就像，它只是飙升，而且 Duolingo 就像是那种每周一到两三小时学习的糟糕版本，就像我学波兰语时常说的笑话，ja lubię kaczka，意思是“我喜欢鸭子”。因为我很快就学会了鸭子，我当时想，为什么我知道这个词？他们教你所有这些动物。
start to do that it starts to reinforce all the things that you kind of studied in your head but it like it's just like it's skyrockets and like Duolingo is like a terrible version of basically like doing that one to two three hours a week like my joke I always used to say when I was learning Polish was, ja lubię kaczka, which means I like ducks. Because I knew ducks so quickly and I was like, why do I know the word? And they teach you all these animals.
我不记得大象，但我过去常说我喜欢粉色大象之类的，因为他们教你的单词集，我不知道如何点餐，我不知道如何……然后有一次，它教了，因为他们教你的单词集，我不知道如何点餐。我不知道如何，然后有一次，你知道，它教了你，比如，哦，对不起。我当时想，哦，就像一个你每天都会说的非常有用的东西。而且有一次，他们还教了信用卡。我当时想，好吧，就像另一个非常有用的东西。当你去那里的商店时，
I can't remember elephant, but I used to say I like pink elephants or whatever it was because the set of words they would teach you and I wouldn't know how to order something, I wouldn't know how to... And then at some point, it taught because like the set of words they would teach you and like I wouldn't know how to order something. I wouldn't know how to and then at some point, you know, it taught you like, oh, I'm sorry. And I was like, oh, like an actually very useful thing that you will say on like the daily basis. And like at one point, they also teach you credit card. And I was like, okay, like another very useful thing. Like when you're in a store there,
他们总是问，你是要现金还是信用卡？通常，作为外国人，你只是，你只是指着你的卡，这非常尴尬。你只是说，是的。我不住在这里，我不知道你在说什么，我只是指着这个东西，但如果你知道如何说信用卡，现在就像你说了信用卡，你说了谢谢，然后砰，你就完成了。就像你是当地人。所以我知道一系列随机的波兰语单词，出于有趣的原因。首先，最重要的是，lodi，也就是冰淇淋。我对此感到非常困扰。
they always ask, like, do you want cash or credit card? And usually, like as a foreigner, you just You just like point to your card and it's very it's very like embarrassing. You're just like yes. I don't live here I have no idea what you're saying I'll just point at this thing, but if you know how to say credit card now It's like you say credit card you say thank you and then poof you're done. It's like you're local So I know about I know a collection of random Polish words That for amusing reasons. First of all, most importantly, lodi, which is ice cream. I'm very troubled by this.
根据 ChatGPT、谷歌翻译和我女朋友的说法，波兰语中没有 gelato 的独特词汇，我认为这是一种食物犯罪。你的语言需要有 gelato 和冰淇淋的独特词汇。但我知道 Lodi。然后我知道 Ramona 多年来用过的各种名字或昵称。所以她的家人过去常叫她 Brudronka，这就像波兰语中瓢虫的意思，听起来有点像 Ramonka，这是 Ramona 名字的随意家庭版本。所以他们会叫她 Ramona Bajronka。然后我有时叫
According to ChatGPT, Google Translate, and my girlfriend, there is no distinct word in Polish for gelato, which I think is like a food crime. Your language needs to have distinct words for gelato and ice cream. But I know Lodi. And then I know a variety of names or nicknames that Ramona has had throughout the years. So her family used to call her Brudronka, which is like the Polish word for ladybug, which kind of sounds like Ramonka, which is the like casual like family version of Ramona's name. So they would call her like Ramona Bajronka. And then I call
她 Ribka，这就像鱼的指小词，因为她喝大量的水。所以我说，你是我的鱼。她说，在波兰语中，情侣之间的昵称会是像叫对方 Ribka 之类的，在英语中就像，我不知道，它对鱼的关系就像 doggy 对狗的关系。但是的，你说的关于沉浸感的部分很有趣，因为 Ramona 的侄女，她两年前来纽约看我们，我注意到她在那里旅行时英语有所提高。当她在汉堡和我们汇合时，最初的三到四天，她，她的英语比较生疏。
her sometimes Ribka, which is like the diminutive of fish, because she just drinks like a ton of water. So I'm like, you're my fish. And she says that like in Polish, like people, like couples nicknames for each other will be to like call each other something like ribca, like which in English would be like, you know, like, I don't know, it is to fish what like doggy is to dog. But yeah, and it was interesting what you're saying about the immersion part of it because Ramona's niece, she came to visit us two years ago in New York and I noticed that her English improved when she was here for the trip. And when she met up with us in Hamburg, the first like three to four days, she was, like her English was rustier.
也许这只是自信心的问题。我总觉得她理解的比她愿意说的要多，因为她能听懂一点，但她觉得说出来不舒服。但到旅行结束时，我可以看出她已经，她的英语恐惧感好多了。我不认为是因为，是的，她通过聊天，通过每天和我们交谈七八天学到了很多东西。但这也是因为沉浸其中。
Maybe it was just a confidence thing. I always feel like she understands more than she's willing to speak because she can understand a bit, but she doesn't feel comfortable speaking. But by the end of the trip, I could tell that she had, like her English apprehension was much better. And I don't think it was that like, yeah, she learned a lot of things just like chatting, like talking with us day to day for seven or eight days. But also it was just like being immersed.
我相信她已经知道的很多事情，你知道，某种程度上浮现在她的脑海中。是的，这很常见。我通常在和 Shima 的家人在一起时不会突然说波斯语。但很多时候，我可以听出不是完整的句子，但我会听到一两个词，然后你可以推断出其余的。所以每隔一段时间，你知道，我会说些什么，然后他们会说，比如，她妈妈总是
I'm sure there are a lot of things that she already knew, you know, sort of came, came to the front of her head. Yeah, it's it, it's very common. Like I don't typically break out into a Persian when I'm with Shima's family. But a lot of the times, like I can pick up on not full sentences, but I'll hear like one or two words, and then you can infer the rest. And so like every once in a while, like, you know, I'll say something and then they'll be like, like, her mom's always
说，哦，在他面前说话不再安全了。他学得太快了。是的，是的。我的意思是，我绝对觉得即使我知道一点点，我也能弄明白一点。而且这很有趣。在西班牙待了几天很有趣，因为它提醒我，我实际上确实
like, Oh, it's not safe to talk around him anymore. Like, he's learning too quickly. Yeah, yeah. I mean, I definitely feel like even with the little bit that I know, I can suss out a little bit. And it's interesting. It was interesting being in Spain for a couple of days, because it reminded me that I do actually
比我想象的知道更多的西班牙语。那么，如果不是应用程序，你推荐什么来学习？我在想看看 Ramona 的侄女是否愿意偶尔和我一起上 WhatsApp，她可以练习英语，我可以练习波兰语，因为我知道这是我过去有同事做过的事情，我以前在 LSU 有个同事，他会在早上 5 点起床，去办公室通过 Skype 和他在中国的朋友练习中文和英语。是的，如果能做到，我 100% 推荐。
know a little bit more Spanish than I think. So what do you recommend for learning, if not the apps? I was thinking to see whether Ramona's niece would want to hop on WhatsApp with me every now and then, and she could practice her English and I could practice my Polish, because I know that's something that I've had colleagues in the past, I had a colleague back at LSU who would wake up at like 5 a.m. and go into the office to Skype his friend in China to for them to mutually practice their Chinese and English. Yeah, I would 100% recommend, if you can do that, recommend that.
我的意思是，当我在，我的最佳建议是搬到说那种语言的国家，它会飙升，实际上当我在中国时，我在 Excel 中建立了一个程序，基本上是我们课堂上学到的所有词汇的汇编，然后我有两种不同的模式，一种是它给我英语，然后我必须大声说出中文发音，另一种是它给我中文字符，然后我必须做同样的事情，
I mean, when I was, I mean, my best recommendation is move to the country where they speak the language It just skyrockets and I actually when I was in China I built a program in Excel that basically was a compilation of all the vocab that we would get in Class and then I had two different modes one where it would feed me the English and then I would have to say out loud the the Chinese pronunciation, and then the other one was where it would give me the Chinese character, and then I'd have to do the same thing,
它的工作方式是，在我大声回答后，我点击一个按钮看看我是否正确，然后我可以点击，比如，我的发音对吗或者一切都对吗？如果我一切都对了，它会把它放在某个列表里，不再向我显示。如果我一切都对了，它会把它放在某个列表里，不再向我显示。
and the way it would work is, after I would answer it out loud, I then click a button to see if I'm right, and then I could click, like, did I get the pronunciation right or everything right? And if I got everything right, it would put it on some list where it wouldn't show me anymore. And if I got everything right, it would put it on some list where it wouldn't show me that anymore.
如果我错了，它会回到列表里。所以随着时间的推移，你知道，里面有几千个单词。它只显示我难以记住的那些。而且，这就像一个，这特别像，这是一种记忆技巧，他们给它起了一个花哨的名字，但它只是一个，它就像一个，你叫它什么？非常直观的方式，比如如果你有抽认卡，每次你拿到一张抽认卡，你总是知道它，你就把它放在一堆里，
And if I got it wrong, it would go back in the list. And so over time, you know, there's a couple thousand words in there. It's only showing me the ones that I have trouble remembering. And that, that is like a, that's specifically like, it's a type of memorization technique that like they put some fancy name on, but it's just like a, it's like a, what do you call it? Very intuitive way, like if you have flashcards and every single time you get a flashcard and you always know it, you put it in a pile
你就不再看它了。是的，我在学校学习时就是这么做的。学校的第二部分，我在大学尝试的那两年，我会要么在电脑上用一些新的抽认卡应用程序做抽认卡。那是在我使用 Linux 的时候。或者我实际上会写出物理抽认卡。我会做同样的事情。
and you don't look at it anymore. Yeah, that's what I used to do when I was studying in school. The second part of school, the two years where I tried in college is I would do either flashcards on the computer with some new flashcard app. This was back when I used Linux. Or I would actually write out physical flashcards. And I'd do the same thing.
但我会做的是，我会把整套卡片过三遍。当我过的时候，每次我过这套抽认卡时，我会，一旦我答对了抽认卡，我就把它放在一边。然后我会继续过我错过的那些。我只会那样做三次。我使用的一种技巧，我至今在做演讲时还在用，就是我尝试在演讲前一天晚上
But what I would do is I would go through the entire set three times. And when I was going through, each time I would go through the set of flashcards, I would, once I got the flashcard right, I would set it aside. And then I would continue going through the ones that I missed. And I would just do that three times. And one technique that I used, which I still use when I'm giving a talk, is I try to go
过一遍演讲。因为我发现，或者我会在考试前一天晚上睡觉前做抽认卡，因为我只是发现，在考试前一天晚上练习材料有助于我更好地记住它，就像做正确的事情。我睡觉。是的。我想这背后有一些科学依据。我不知道。是的。是的。绝对有研究。所以我的意思是，这并不是我所知道的任何应用程序中内置的。
over the talk the night before I'm going to give it. Because I find, or I would do the flashcards right before I go to sleep the night before the test because I just find that doing the like practicing the material the night before it helps me retain it better like doing it right. I sleep. Yeah. I think there's some science behind that. I don't know. Yeah. Yeah. There's there's definitely like research. So I mean that so that's like that's not really built into any of the apps that I know of.
我会说只要使用你喜欢的任何应用程序。即使它们很糟糕，它们仍然是学习词汇的好方法。你在上波斯语课吗？我曾经有一个导师，但只持续了一次，尽管我付了五次的钱，因为我太社交尴尬了，我无法要求我想要的东西。所以它是虚拟的。我的意思是它是虚拟的
I would say just use whatever app that you like. Even though they're terrible, there's still a good way to pick up vocab or whatever. Are you taking a class for Persian? I had a tutor at one point, but it lasted one session, even though I paid for five, because I'm so socially awkward and I couldn't ask for what I wanted. So it was virtual. I mean it was virtual
但我不想学习如何写，她强迫我写，我试图表达，我们能跳过这一部分吗？我只想学习如何说。她说，是的，是的，然后就忽略了我所说的，所以就是那样，但我并没有真正和 Shima 练习，因为她会说波斯语，但不是超级流利。所以老实说，我的建议是，如果你有渠道，并且你通过 Ramona
but I didn't want to learn how to write and she was like forcing me to write and I kind of was I tried to like Articulate like can we just skip this part? I just want to learn how to speak and She was like, yes. Yes, and then just ignored what I said and and so that was that but I don't I don't really practice with Shima because she speaks Persian, but not like super fluently. And so honestly, my recommendation is if you have access and you do via Ramona
和 Ramona 的家人有渠道，那就是当你在一起时，你知道，你默默地听，试着学点东西。但随着时间的推移，你可以做一些小事，比如你可以说单个单词。当你告别时，用波兰语告别。在波斯语中，是 chora hafez。每个人都在说。所以就像，哦，对了，我知道那个词。然后你就那样说，然后每个人，哦，这个人正在学习，很可爱。但随着时间的推移，你只是，所以那些单词，我不必考虑像告别，波斯语不是波斯语，就像它自动地，它就
and Ramona's family is is when you hang out like, you know, you silently listen and try and pick up things. But like slowly over time, there's small things that you can do to just like you can say one off words. When you say goodbye, say goodbye in Polish. In Persian, it's chora hafez. Everyone's saying it. And so it's like, oh, right, I know that word. And so then you say that and then everyone, oh, it's very cute that the person's learning. But then slowly over time, you just like, so then those words, I don't have to think about like goodbye and purges not Persian like I just it's automatically like it goes
当你学习一门语言时，有一些短语，他们喜欢，这就是他们谈论的，比如当你真正流利时，你可以用那种语言做梦，就像我学中文时，我达到了那种程度，甚至现在，有一些事情，比如当你像说“我不知道”，那可能是你学习语言时最常说的话之一。在中文里，我永远不会忘记。Will brujie dao？
and when you're when you're learning a language there's certain phrases that they like it's what they talk about like when you're really fluent you can dream in the language which is like when I was learning Chinese like I got to the point where I was doing that and like it even now like there's certain things like when you say like I don't know that's probably like one of the most common things you're gonna say when learning a language. And in Chinese, like I'll never forget that. Will brujie dao?
是的，我现在可能把那个发音搞砸了。但你想要开始像那样获得那些短语，并尽可能多地说它们。是的，如果你要和你的侄女做点什么，我会说学习这个短语，你想要达到雪球真正开始滚动的程度。那就是你可以基本上，你有足够的流利度，虽然流利是错误的词，你知道足够的语言，即使你不明白她在说什么，你可以说，比如在中文里，我想是 well booming by Nikoi jedzima，意思是“我不明白，但你能解释一下吗？”然后一旦你有那个，足够的中文或足够的
Yeah, I'm probably butchering the pronunciation of that now. But like you want to start like getting those phrases and and saying them as like much as possible. And yeah, if you're going to do something with like your niece, I would say learn the phrase like you want to get to the point where the snowball really starts rolling. And that's where you can basically you have enough like fluency although fluency is the wrong word like you know enough the language that even if you don't understand what she's saying you can say like in Chinese I think it was like a well booming by Nikoi jedzima which means I don't understand but could you explain and then as soon as you have that that like enough Chinese or enough?
波斯语或足够的波兰语，你可以说那个，他们会切换到你可能知道的词汇的更简单的语言，然后你就开始比赛了，那就是它真正开始像滚雪球一样的时候，因为你有足够的应付，你只是不知道所有的单词，而且你有时听力有困难。这都是说，你需要接触这些人，无论你是搬到那个国家，还是有家人，还是有伴侣，或者有人在那里建立一个基本上可以进行这种对话的应用程序。我真的现在有一个 50 件事的清单，前五名是建立一个专门的波斯语学习应用程序，做完全
Persian or enough Polish that you can say that they'll switch into simpler language of The vocab that you probably know and then you're off to the races and that's when it like really starts snowballing because you have enough to get By you just like you just don't know all the words and and you have trouble listening sometimes Which is all to say that like you need have access to these people, whether you go move to the country or have family or have a partner or someone out there builds an app that basically can have this conversation. And literally I have a list of 50 things now and in the top five is build a specifically a Persian learning app that does exactly
这种事情。基本上，我只想坐在那里交谈，说，哦，抱歉，我不明白。因为有些应用程序，比如 Monly，确实有这种来回对话，你可以进行对话，但你必须阅读它给你的单词。你不能编造你想说的话。所以这是一个有脚本的对话，仍然是。你确实有点像，哦，你好，你好。你今天怎么样？巴，巴，巴。
this kind of thing. And that basically like, I just want to sit there and converse and be like, oh, sorry, I didn't understand that. Because there's some apps like Monly does have this kind of back and forth conversation where you have a conversation, but you have to read the words that it's giving you. You don't get to make up what you want to say. And so it's a scripted conversation, which still is. You do kind of like, it's like, oh, hello, hello. How's your day? Bah, bah, bah.
但这并不是你真正会做的事情，对吧？它会给你一组单词。就像，好吧，我实际上不知道那是什么意思。所以你只是在猜测。不管怎样，所以。所以波斯语不是 Shima 的第一语言，对吧？她的母语是英语？呃……
But it's not exactly what you would be doing, right? It's going to give you some set of words. And it's like, well, I don't actually know what that means. So you're just kind of guessing. Anyways, so. So Persian was not Shema's first language, right? Her native tongue is English? Uh...
我应该知道这个。我的意思是，她出生在波斯，所以……哦，所以也许，但她不是在很小的时候就搬走了吗？是的，是的，她搬走时非常小。所以我认为六个月后，他们搬到德国待了一会儿，然后他们最后搬到了加拿大，我想她当时两岁，所以你永远不知道她什么时候开始学英语，这是一个好问题，我实际上不知道。我的意思是她的英语很完美，对吧？所以我的意思是人们不时在播客上听到她说话，所以我立刻，是的，因为这很有趣
I should know this. I mean, she was born in Persia, so... Oh, so maybe, but didn't she move when she was real young? Yeah, yeah, she moved when she was very young, though. So I think after six months, they moved to Germany for a little bit, and then they ended up moving to Canada, I think she was two so you never tell when did she start learning English that's a good question I don't actually know I mean her English is perfect right so I mean people have heard her speak from time to time on the podcast so I would immediately yeah because it's interesting
对于 Ramona，你知道，她的母语是波兰语。她住在波兰，她 17 岁。她直到来到美国才说任何英语。她 17 岁来到美国，上了高中，学会了英语。然后她在美国的余生中，她并没有真正有那么多，或者至少过去几年，她没有很多波兰语使用者可以互动。所以有时当她和家人交谈时，尽管波兰语是她的母语，
with Ramona because Ramona, you know, her native language is Polish. She lived in Poland and she was 17. She didn't speak any English until she came to the US. And she came to the US when she was 17, went into high school, learned English. And then for most of her life in the US, she's not really had that many, or at least the last couple of years, she's not had a ton of Polish speakers to interact with. And so sometimes when she's talking to her family, even though Polish is her native tongue,
她有，她找不到她需要的词。她说，哦，我必须去手机上查这个词，我知道英语，但我不知道波兰语。我只是觉得这是一个迷人的现象，因为波兰语是她的母语。并不是说她完全失去了它，但我认为至少她的波兰语和英语是同样
she's got like, she can't find the words that she needs. She's like, oh, I have to go look on my phone to find this word that I know in English, but I don't know in Polish. And I just think it's a fascinating phenomenon because Polish was her native language. And it's not like she's entirely lost it, but I think that at the very least her Polish and English are equally
强大的，但我认为她的英语实际上比她的波兰语更强。我认为英语更多是她的，你知道，它不是她的母语，但它是她现在的第一语言。是的，我的意思是如果你考虑一下，在拼字游戏词典中，作为词典的参考，我想有 13.8 万个单词。我的意思是大多数人不知道其中的一半，但你常用的那些，
strong, but I think her English is actually stronger than her Polish. I think that English is more of her her, you know, it's not her native tongue, but it's her first language now. Yeah, well I mean if you think about it, like in the Scrabble Dictionary, just as a reference of a dictionary, I think there's like a hundred thirty-eight thousand words. I mean most people don't know like half of those, but the ones that you use commonly,
我想有两到四千个左右。所以有太多的单词处于边缘，你知道它，但你会一年用一次，每几年用一次，当它是，你知道，如果你在谈论某种政治事情，或者，某种领域特定的事情，你知道这些词，它在你的大脑深处，但它太容易忘记那些东西，如果你在学习这门语言，也不知道那些东西。这就是人们过去常说的，哦，你的中文太棒了。你很流利。
I think there's like two to four thousand of them or something. And so there's so many words that are on the edge of like, you know it, but like you'll use it once a year, once every a couple years when it's like it's, you know, if you're talking about some political thing or, you know, some domain specific thing, like, you know the words it's in the back of your brain, but like, it's so easy to forget that stuff and also not know that stuff if you're learning the language., like that's the thing is people used to say, oh, like your Chinese is amazing. You're fluent.
但我说，如果我不能就当前的政治气候以及正在竞选哪个党派和哪个党派的政客进行对话，你实际上并不流利，对吧？你不能就任何事情进行对话。就像不，我可以出去玩得开心。去参加一些舞蹈课，去参加一些棋盘游戏活动，并与人们完全交谈。但如果他们开始深入探讨，比如，我不知道，大学羽毛球场景
But I was like, if I can't have a conversation about the current like political climate and like the politicians that are running for what party and whatever party like you're not actually fluent, right? You can't have a conversation about like anything. It's like no, I can go out and have a good time. Go to some dance class, go to some board game event and like totally converse with people. But if they start dropping down into like the intricacies of like the, I don't know, the collegiate badminton scene
在中国和崭露头角的人，我知道羽毛球这个词，或者当时知道，但我不知道如何跟上那个对话。不管怎样，所以我的观点是这很容易。我不认为我们意识到我们的词汇集有多么广泛，但我们每周实际使用的百分比正是它是一个超长的尾巴。所以忘记那些东西太容易了。
in China and the up and coming people, I know the word for badminton or did at the time, but like, I don't know how to follow that conversation. Anyways, so my point being is it's very easy. Like, I don't think we realize like how expansive like our vocab set is, but like, the percentage that we actually use on a weekly basis is exactly it's a super long tail. So like, it's so easy to forget that stuff.
所有语言的常用词汇量都是 2 到 4k 吗？我的意思是，这可能是数量级，这是真的。但我不知道是否有语言的常用词汇量小得多或大得多。我认为这是，我实际上是从学习中文中偷来的，他们说你需要知道 2 到 4000 个字符，因为一个字符映射到一个单词，很多人对此感到挣扎，这就是为什么我专门建立了那个程序来练习
Is that true of all languages where they have the folks that the common vocab size is like two to 4k? I mean, it's probably order of magnitude, it's true. But I wonder whether there's languages where the common vocab size is a lot smaller or a lot larger. I think that's, I actually stole that from learning Chinese, is that they say you need to know like 2 to 4,000 characters because a single character maps to a word, which a lot of people struggle with, which is why I specifically built that program to practice
我的字符识别。但我认为总的来说这是真的，对吧？他们说阅读报纸需要 2000 到 4000 个字符或单词。这个想法是关于报纸的，尽管他们在谈论很多不同的事情，总的来说实际上，我知道这一点，因为我爸爸是一名记者，你是应该倾向于更简单的语言。我爸爸过去常开玩笑说，他年轻时会说，有大量的选择，或者也许是我阿姨会那样说来烦我爸爸，因为那些是“大量的”和“过多的”两个听起来不错的词。但我记得我爸爸曾经说过，他说你永远不会把它放在报纸文章里，因为你在写给大众看。所以你不会去寻找那些可能有四五个音节，可能不在每个人的词汇表里的单词。
my character recognition. But I think in general it's true, right? And they say it's 2,000 to 4,000 characters or words to read a newspaper. And the idea is about newspapers, even though they're talking about a bunch of different things, in general actually, and I know this because my dad's a reporter, is you're supposed to lean towards simpler language. My dad used to always joke that he would say when he was younger, there's a veritable plethora
我的汉字识别能力。但我认为总的来说这是对的，对吧？他们说读报纸需要两千到四千个汉字或词汇。关于报纸的理念是，尽管它们讨论各种不同的事情，但总的来说——我之所以知道这一点是因为我父亲是记者——你应该倾向于使用更简单的语言。我父亲过去常开玩笑说，他年轻时会说“有大量的选择”，
of options, or maybe it was my aunt that would say that to bug my dad, because those are veritable and plethora are two nice sounding words. But I remember my dad saying once, he was like, you'd never put that in a newspaper article because you're writing to inform the masses. And so you're not going to reach for words that are four or five syllables that might not be in everyone's lexicon or vocabulary
或者可能是我的阿姨为了逗我父亲而那样说，因为“veritable”（名副其实的）和“plethora”（过剩）是两个听起来很不错的词。但我记得我父亲曾说过，他说你永远不会把这些词写进报纸文章里，因为你是为了向大众提供信息而写作。所以你不会去用那些可能有四五个音节、且不在每个人的词汇量范围内的词。
because people aren't going to understand it. I wonder if there is some lesson here for interactions with large language models. Should you use simpler language when talking to an LLM because the simpler language is going to activate more in its weights than more obscure words that it just has less information about. I don't know. I do not know.
因为人们不会理解它。我想知道这对与大型语言模型交互是否有什么启示。在与大语言模型交流时，是否应该使用更简单的语言，因为简单的语言比那些模型信息量较少的晦涩词汇更能激活其权重？我不知道。我真的不知道。
Although I do know that lately with like esoteric stuff, if you're super specific about it, it is actually amazing. Like I asked it a question about BQN the other day, which notoriously these models aren't fantastic with array languages, let alone the bleeding edge ones that have been invented in the last like five years. And it absolutely nailed it. Like I was asking if you could do some pattern matching, destructuring thing in the header of a function, which is specific to BQN, like APL and friends don't have it. And it was like, unfortunately, like you can't do what you want.
虽然我知道最近对于一些深奥的东西，如果你表达得非常具体，效果其实非常惊人。比如前几天我问了它一个关于 BQN 的问题，众所周知，这些模型在处理数组语言方面表现并不出色，更不用说过去五年才发明出来的尖端语言了。但它完全答对了。我当时问的是是否可以在函数头中进行某种模式匹配和解构，这是 BQN 特有的，像 APL 之类的语言都没有。它回答说，很遗憾，你不能那样做。
Like you can do it this way, you can do it this way. And it was it was 100% correct. And so the point being is, I think it is actually if like if you go to some corner of the model, it is actually still quite good, even if it's got a smaller corpus of stuff. Speaking, actually, well, should we got this? Well, it is a perfect transition. All right, maybe we'll transition. We might come back to the to hear more about the Kuta trip.
它说你可以这样做，也可以那样做。而且它是百分之百正确的。所以重点是，我认为如果你深入到模型的某个特定领域，它其实还是相当不错的，即使它的相关语料库较小。说到这个，嗯，我们应该谈谈这个吗？好吧，这算是一个完美的过渡。好的，也许我们会过渡一下。我们可能会回来听听更多关于 CUDA 之旅的内容。
You know, I mentioned that it's on my list. Ask about the Kuta trip. What were you going to say? Okay, yeah, spend five minutes. Just I'm curious. How did that go? You know, because you were giving talks at most of these places, correct? True or false?
你知道，我提到过这在我的清单上。问问关于 CUDA 之旅的事。你刚才想说什么？好的，是的，花五分钟时间。我只是很好奇。那次行程怎么样？因为你在大多数地方都做了演讲，对吧？是这样吗？
Yeah, it was great. I was just putting my trip report together yesterday. Yeah, great audiences. It was interesting in Hamburg. There were some number of people from ISC, the International Supercomputing Conference, which is like the European version of the supercomputing conference that we have in the US. And so a bunch of people from that came to the C++ user
是的，很棒。我昨天刚整理好我的旅行报告。观众非常棒。在汉堡的那次很有趣。有一些来自 ISC（国际超级计算大会）的人，这是欧洲版的超级计算大会，就像我们在美国的那个一样。所以有一群人从那里来到 C++ 用户
group, and then there were some locals too. And so a bunch of people from that came to the C++ user group and then there were some locals too. And just great questions, ton of great questions there. Like people were grilling me. We spent like an extra 30 minutes there on Q&A. But all around, yeah, pretty much all the meetups, very engaged audiences. You know, it was a mix of some of the meetups for people who weren't that familiar with CUDA, weren't that familiar with HPC. Some of them were people who were very familiar with CUDA and HPC.
小组，还有一些当地人。那里的人提问非常踊跃，有大量精彩的问题。他们简直是在盘问我。我们在问答环节多花了大约 30 分钟。总的来说，几乎所有的聚会，观众参与度都非常高。你知道，有些聚会的人对 CUDA 不太熟悉，对高性能计算（HPC）也不太熟悉，而有些聚会的人则对 CUDA 和 HPC 非常了解。
But it was sort of applicable for everybody because we were essentially showing, here's how we want you to think about teaching and learning and using CUDA today. So it's like we're rethinking how we educate. And I think the dog is here because it's around time for her to get food and she wants to remind me that she's hungry. But she still has at least 22 minutes before she gets to eat and hopefully you're not interfering with the mic front too much.
但这对每个人都适用，因为我们本质上是在展示：这就是我们希望你们今天如何思考教学、学习和使用 CUDA 的方式。所以我们是在重新思考教育方式。我想狗在这里是因为快到她吃饭的时间了，她想提醒我她饿了。但她至少还有 22 分钟才能吃饭，希望你没有太干扰麦克风。
But yeah, and a lot of students, in particular at the London meetup, it was at University College of London. And we did a raffle at the end of the meetup, where one of the things we raffled away was lunch with Andy Terrell and me and two undergraduate students one and so we had lunch with them on Sunday and that was really nice. One of them was a law student who was into tech and so she came with all the CS students to our very, very deeply technical meetup. And yeah, I mean, it was great.
但是，是的，有很多学生，特别是在伦敦的聚会，是在伦敦大学学院举行的。我们在聚会结束时举行了抽奖，其中一个奖项是和我、Andy Terrell 以及两名本科生共进午餐。所以我们在周日和他们一起吃了午饭，那真的很不错。其中一名是法律系学生，她对科技很感兴趣，所以她和所有的计算机系学生一起来参加我们非常、非常硬核的技术聚会。是的，我的意思是，这太棒了。
I think I had a great time. I'm really happy with the talks that I gave there. I'm going to be doing a few more meetups later this year. Was this the toolbox talk that we did a whole episode on earlier, or was this a very, Yeah, so the C++ talk I was giving was the toolbox talk. And I want to, and basically the, that toolbox talk is presenting a new view of how you should learn CUDA and think
我觉得我玩得很开心。我对我在那里做的演讲非常满意。今年晚些时候我还会参加更多的聚会。这就是我们之前做过一整期节目的工具箱演讲吗，还是说这是一个非常……是的，我做的 C++ 演讲就是工具箱演讲。我想，基本上那个工具箱演讲展示了你应该如何学习 CUDA 和思考
about CUDA. So it's like, if you like if you, it's an overview of like, here's how you should write CUDA C++ code. And like, if you don't know anything about CUDA C++, here's a good place to start. But even if you do know stuff about CUDA C++, it's still good content to watch, to understand what levels of abstraction should you be working at. And one of the key takeaways is you should start at the
CUDA 的新视角。所以，如果你喜欢的话，这是一个概述，告诉你应该如何编写 CUDA C++ 代码。如果你对 CUDA C++ 一无所知，这是一个很好的起点。但即使你了解一些 CUDA C++，观看这些内容来理解你应该在什么抽象层级上工作仍然很有价值。其中一个关键要点是，你应该从
high level of abstractions. You should start with using libraries, et cetera. And I want to make a Python version of that talk, which is sort of like an intro to CUDA Python. But the Python version of the talk that I was giving was about how you can write kernels in CUDA Python and exploring a couple different cool kernels. I think we talk about softmax and a row-wise sum.
高层抽象开始。你应该从使用库等开始。我想做一个该演讲的 Python 版本，类似于 CUDA Python 入门。但我做的那个演讲的 Python 版本是关于你如何在 CUDA Python 中编写内核，并探索几个不同的酷内核。我想我们讨论了 Softmax 和行求和。
I think I cut out the summed area table problem from that talk, which is one that I think you and I have talked about in the past. But that's more of like a price algorithms talk. I mean, okay, they're all kind of price algorithms talks. Yeah, I'll leave links to both the sum area table episode. And we also did an episode on the toolbox. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at adspthepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion Cool Bucks. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我想我从那个演讲中删掉了求和面积表问题，这是我认为你和我过去讨论过的一个问题。但这更像是一个算法演讲。我的意思是，好吧，它们都是某种算法演讲。是的，我会留下求和面积表那一期的链接。我们还做了一期关于工具箱的节目。请务必查看你的播客应用或 adspthepodcast.com 上的节目说明，获取我们今天提到的任何内容的链接，以及 GitHub 讨论 Cool Bucks 的链接。本期节目还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。